you know anna anna after after they said
penetration in the end zone they lost me
so sonny is this a sign that this
by the way that inappropriate joke i
made for daytime television
scratch it make believe i never said it
make believe i never said it so treat it
like any other joy behar joke
[Music]
[Applause]
all right talk about a super tuesday
america
finally caitlyn jenner is on the show
great to see her
she was here all day we had a great time
in the park today
[Music]
she is limber and we always always have
fun
unlike jimmy kimmel boy what a sad slide
he's been on
[Music]
[Applause]
reminds me of his ratings they're lower
than joy reid's iq
now if you told my 10 year old self that
i'd have caitlyn jenner
on my talk show i'd be like i have a
talk show
and who is caitlyn jenner then i would
tell my ten-year-old self who caitlyn
jenner is
and i'd be like holy
what the hell is going on with this
world
then i would ask is mr t still mr t
but then i would calm down and i'd be
totally psyched
so when you have a sports legend on your
show who's also trans you're going to
have to tackle
the elephant in the room you have to
paraphrase roy scheider and jaws
we're going to need a bigger wheaties
box
yes the olympics welcomes its first
trans athlete
and thankfully uh we have a few athletes
on this panel tonight to talk about this
not cat of course the last time she ran
anywhere was from the police
but as a as a former olympic athlete i
do have some thoughts
yep i bet you didn't know i was in the
olympics i sure was until they banned
the dwarf toss
but i even made i even made it on the
wheaties box
here you go take that count chocula
still i don't know how much i should
care about women's weightlifting
my idea of women's weightlifting is
watching cat try to pick up my wallet
and can you find a smaller subgroup of
society than women's weightlifting
in new zealand well maybe seth meyers
fans
i know
and who knew new zealand had an olympic
team i mean i know they have a
government
they're quite a sturdy bunch so out of
seven billion people the trans athlete
issue is commanding quite a space
but should everyone have an opinion i
live by a very simple rule
don't get angry about anything if the
people closer to the issue
aren't angry first i came up with that
rule a week after i was married
meaning if the people directly impacted
by this stuff aren't willing to speak up
then why should i
now maybe they're pissed off but they
can't say so because they're scared for
the very same reasons everyone is scared
today
they don't want to be ostracized for
their beliefs in the modern era of
wokism even people
possessing real experience that enables
them to speak out
they get swarmed by the mob too just
happened to rita moreno
she had to apologize for defending a
non-white director for not being woke
enough
but then again we are talking female
weightlifters
why should they be scared of anyone they
can crush you with their thighs
and they charge a lot for that on
craigslist
[Laughter]
i really should get a new safe word it's
harder
my point is my point is the people
the people who should be getting upset
about competing against trans athletes
should be the athletes their parents
their significant others their
co-workers at the postal service
but if they can't voice their opinions
because they fear attacks by hardcore
activists
how can the rest of us help maybe that's
the point
people critical of trans athletes
competing against biological women bring
up the hard work biological women put
into their training
all to see them losing their spot to an
athlete who looks like me
in a onesie there's a reason why people
take male hormones to enhance
performance
now you could have separate teams for
male female and trans but god forbid we
violate the awoke sacred rule of
inclusion
you could do away with all criteria
altogether and let humans play together
like co-ed soccer back in school but
except a real sport
but even in those games you can't escape
the innate sex differences rules usually
require an equal number of sexes per
team
because men and women are different
something i have to remind myself when i
accidentally walk into the wrong sauna
at planet fitness
it's not common in head-to-head sports
to have men compete against women due to
physiology
but in open-class sports you can mix up
the sexes you know like a party at cat's
apartment
in equestrian sports females compete
with male jockeys in dog-sled racing
male and female mushers directly compete
in the ncaa men and women compete
against one another in
rifle shooting which is great prep work
if you're planning to move to chicago
you know there's ultimate frisbee which
allows people of different genders to
match
up and play usually between their shifts
at hot topic
but after that my analysis collapses
like a chinese-made
lawn ornament those are the exceptions
which might prove the rule we are
dancing around the 400 pound weight
lifter in the room
sex differences not you tyrus
it's everywhere
ah they could have caught him but
but sex differences are everywhere
including this sport
that's curling now maybe this sport
should be female cause it involves a
broom and sweeping
is something a sexist might say
and something that i would condemn
so we live in a time where we can't
speak the truth the gulf between our
thoughts and words is wider than an
olympic soccer field and it keeps
getting wider
especially about biology which is a
shame because we could actually make
progress
if we were open about the progress
itself
let's welcome tonight's guests her
preferred pronoun is
winner california gubernatorial
candidate caitlyn jenner
this mercedes has liberals looking like
fiats
american conservative union foundation
senior fellow mercedes
her tongue is so sharp she's only ever
eaten braided cheese
foxy's contributor cat's him
and try to follow in his footsteps then
you'll spend a lot of time climbing
out of his footsteps my massive sidekick
and joseph's upset on fox station
tyrus
caitlin i'm here
i would say you're here you're queer get
used to it but we've heard that before
i know but we talked a couple of weeks
ago right
for the first time i thought we kind of
bonded i think we did
i i thought it was a great one when you
sent me those photos oh my god oh my god
were you excited about them i was
excited three or four times over the
course of an evening
actually actually before we get started
i have a very personal question sure for
you
absolutely uh i would like to know the
answer this i heard it through the rumor
mill
what and the question is
do you have a bug-eyed sprite um
i don't know i don't you don't no no i
heard this through some people in the
bug-eyed world
i have a bug it's a car a little oh
have a nash metropolitan which i sold to
dana perino at a loss
no way yes because she can drive a hard
bargain really
yeah that's the only thing she could no
i have a book i thought we had that in
common i thought would be a good way to
start it off no but you know what it was
close enough because i'm a car junkie
and you're a car junkie
i i do enjoy pat's just a junkie
[Laughter]
you're right i can't stop doing so many
drugs
all the time all day long drugs it's how
do i come to work every single
day i'm guessing high high you're right
incredibly high
where am i i don't know where you are
tyrus good to see you oh it was a
pleasure cyrus had
almost missed his flight because of a
storm but i told him he had to get here
because you were on
you told me yes okay there's been a lot
of lies set in this monologue today so
i'm gonna correct a few things
okay number one i am always forever
as long as i grace the presence on this
show the elephant in the room
okay let's just keep that real number
two
it's 356 pound weight lifter get it
right
and three you had no idea what a
bug-eyed sprite was
you went through i saw it in your little
gleam of your eyes every perverted thing
you've ever done in your life
and you tried to figure what you did
with a can of sprite
in somebody's glass eyeball i guarantee
you
and i think and i think there was a
cicada probably
involved okay you were
deeply concerned no i thought okay
somebody in my past reached out to
caitlyn jenner
and told him about something i didn't
[Music]
do we even want to talk about this topic
i can think of nothing i am less
qualified to talk about the only thing
that i have less experience with than
being transgender is probably playing
sports
yes
and i've been weightlifting for
literally pretty much my whole life and
powerlifting is a hobby my only issue
and it's been consistent through this
whole thing
is when it comes to genetics when you
break down
dna if you are more inherently male if
you have male testosterone emotionally
you're going to be stronger you're going
to have more develop
muscles in your shoulder and stuff which
is a huge advantage with lifting
so i kind of feel that there should be a
third division
for fairness but in term in this
situation
this individual isn't even in the top
five so it's still
as far as world class goes there is an
unfair advantage if you
are genetically male right in
competition just because that's just
how it how it is so that's my only issue
i have no problem with
being the olympian i think it's great
but i think we need to be aware of that
i
i am bug-eyed sprite my high school my
high school mock trial team was totally
co-ed
well let me tell you caitlin the one so
the the athlete isn't in the top five
but what if she knocked somebody out to
get her position from say the new
zealand team is that
wrong i mean should the parent i just
don't hear enough about the other how
the other athletes feel
um yeah from an athlete's standpoint i
think a lot of women
especially when it gets down to younger
athletes
okay at that level the olympic committee
has been dealing with this issue for a
very very long time to be honest with
you back in the 60s
they started taking saliva tests of all
of the female athletes to make sure
their dna was right this is the years of
the
east german women right the soviet women
yes
i mean i was in the weight room my last
lifting workout
and this east german girl came in
and she was out lifting me oh i mean
this girl was so strong
caitlyn are you sure it was a girl she
was a girl well she took the test okay
they've been dealing with this issue for
a long time and they do have guidelines
and supposedly she has followed all of
the guidelines
so i have to respect that but it's when
like in the state of california
obviously when it gets down to high
school levels
yeah where there's a massive difference
then it becomes unfair
and there's no regulations at that level
that's true oh and it has to be looked
at
yeah it's honestly if they if you
pass everything that the olympic
committee put out i
i am okay with that yeah yeah yeah i'm
okay with it but and not at the younger
not controlled if i was tested i would
pass a lot of things
well mercedes yeah well i have five
daughters and one of them
is a lacrosse player in high school and
that's always a big concern it's
protecting the girls sports i think yeah
and
what's been you know i don't want like
tyrus to like go and get a lacrosse
stick and compete against my
you know daughter or anything like that
that could be you just shattered my
dreams
although i could see you wearing a
really cute skirt tyrus i don't know
but uh that's more his world i just kind
of sit here but for these girls that
have fur
just asking you to try it on once tyrus
but for these girls who
practice day in and out that really you
know that's
their focus and think about it for
decades how many
female players have been out there
advocating for we need to give more
resources to girls sports
because guess who gets all the resources
yeah the boys sports the football
programs the baseball programs
that is why you need to have more of
this more resources than mock trial gets
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else